die welt steht jetzt gerade vor einer
sehr spannenden frage erdogan oder tram
wer kriegt seine demokratie schneller
kaputt das klären wir jetzt mit die tot
ist
alter das ist doch kein kampf das ist
ein massaker
da muss man sich doch nur mal die hütten
dann gucken ob a tramp wohnt in diesem
unseligen 132 zimmer plattenbau budget
hat in seinem palast ein nachbau des
weißen hauses und zwar als gäste puncto
trump redet über folter erdogan schweigt
und genießt punkt für rd oder nimmt die
frau das ist die rolle von donald hat
auch schon ein paar kilometer runter
dagegen die türkische first lady naja
sagen wir unentschieden
trump dieser diktatoren azubi kann
maximal acht jahre regieren
erdogan hat seine neue verfassung so
geschrieben dass er theoretisch bis 2034
am ruder bleibt 2034 wahrscheinlich auch
das jahr in dem kanzlerin merkel ihn zum
letzten mal in den arsch kriecht er
trank schon längst orange farbener staub
im wind sieg für ergo auf ganzer linie
seien wir mal ehrlich die amis verdanken
den türken alles den ganzen laden geht
es doch gar nicht ohne uns sich schon im
jahr 11 178 300 jahre vor kolumbus sind
muslimische seefahrer nach amerika
gelangt
das sind erwiesen alternative fakten
damals nämlich der türkische animateur
murat columbus mit seiner spaß banane
von antalya über den atlantik gebracht
hatte also ein bisschen mehr respekt und
merkst du doch mal die pforten des
matchs fragebögen kirche
tschüss
[Applaus]